-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
This week, I spent out
the #ThatsMyFamily.
And I asked you to tweet out
your family --
funny or silly family quirks.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think with Prince Harry,
a lot of people are just
looking at their own family and
going, "Well, we're weird too."
Anyways, I thought I'd share
some of my favorite tweets
from you guys.
This first one's from
@fiestared. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow.
-Wow. Frugal.
-Genius.
-You know?
Get the creamers, too.
-That's my family.
This is from @reneejordan78.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-God bless.
-This one's from @babewho.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a family tradition.
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
-I'll take that on some French
toast. Your rectum.
-Ah, thank --
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
Can't say them both in --
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @chelsiegonzo.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Good morning."
-"Morning."
-This one is from
@dasnapesofwrath. They said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Chanting indistinctly ]
-That's a coven.
-This one's from @gorhambetsy.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
He doesn't exist.
-Yeah. "He's not here."
-This one's from
@jakewilliamsart. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one here is fantastic.
This is from @clairelinkhart.
She says...
[ Audience ohs ]
That's the -- Look at --
[ Audience ohs louder ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, my!
[ Laughing ]
There you have it. Those are
our "tonight show" hashtags.
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.